Coming in to Samuel L. Jackson as Shaft, it was no different.
I wanted to really embrace him as Shaft two thousand.
And come up with ideas that would give that same kind of power to Sam
in the character and fashion. It was also a fashion statement.
Well, because those letters are much more subtle than the hard leather
that Richard Roundtree wore.
Weren't they? The ones you put Sam in.
Yeah. With Shaft two thousand.
I'm just trying to, you know, I'm paying attention, that's all.
You are!
I'm just a trained journalist seeking fullness of detail.
That's all I'm doing here for you Ruth.
But you dress characters and we can see the swagger in them.
You want us to get a sense of how these people,
these characters plant their feet on the ground.
And it's funny to say that, but I get a sense of even.
Seeing somebody from the shoulders up when you costume them what shoes they're wearing.
I can tell from the way they're standing, you know,
There's a kind of a pride that goes all the way down, isn't there?
Yeah, there is. I think of Eddie in Dolemite.
He had to wear a lot of platform shoes and, you know, guys aren't wearing those anymore.
So, you know, just the whole idea of it was I'm sure we laughed about it,
But poor Eddie had to wear them.
And after a while we had to decide what shots were not.
seeing his feet so he could put his tennis shoes back on.
But he does say that the costume design does help him give a get a sense of his posture.
And his his gait, and it does support his performance.
And to hear someone iconic like Eddie Murphy say that, it's wonderful.